(audience cheering)
- We are back with
Dame Helen Mirren and Adam Brody.
Give it up everybody!
(audience cheering)
You can see them in
Shazam Fury Of The Gods
It's in theaters now.
In honor of Dame Helen
and St. Patrick's Day.
It is time for a green beer drinking game.
We are calling.
You're Damed if you do.
(fanfair music)
- [Announcer] You damed if you do.
(Kelly laughs)
- I like that.
Alright, Jesse.
Well how it works is.
- [Adam] I'm gonna go here.
- I'm gonna hit this button
and it's never too early.
It's five o'clock somewhere
and a scenario will appear
on the screen over here.
Then much like the drinking
game, "Never have I ever".
Dame Helen, Adam and I
will drink some green beer
if we have done the thing.
So.
- So Without saying
anything we just take a sip?
- [Kelly] You take a sip. No,
I'm gonna totally ask you.
(Helen laughs)
- We take a sip if we have
done the thing or haven't.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- If we have.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All right.
Yes, Okay so then we'll explain ourselves.
That's what we're gonna
do after we take a sip.
So here's the first one.
Here we go.
(gameshow sounds)
(ding sound)
Okay. Oh gosh.
What? Are you serious?
- [Adam] No, no.
(Helen laughs)
- I might have done but I'm
not gonna tell the story.
- Oh.
Oh.
- He has to.
- [Kelly] I've Multiple times.
- She's not playing.
- [Kelly] I've like multiple times.
I love being naked.
Naked is fun.
(audience cheers)
- Can I ask?
- It's never not funny.
And then the older you get,
gravity makes it even funnier.
(Helen laughs)
- Can I ask a technical question?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Is this skinny dipping?
Does it have to be in public or
can it be a pool if its private?
- [Kelly] No, just skinny
dipping. Yeah. Naked.
- [Helen] Oh, in that case.
- Okay. Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
- He was like how do I
get her drink that beer?
(Helen laughs)
- [Kelly] So wait what was your story?
- Not a story.
You know, a few pools.
Never.
- [Kelly] Yeah okay.
- [Kelly] Never a lake?
- I don't even think
I've ever swam in a lake.
- [Kelly] What?
- I am a freak.
I'm afraid.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I mean ocean lake pool.
- [Adam] Yeah.
I don't know haven't had
a lot of lakes in my life.
Lot of ocean though.
- [Kelly] Oh.
I grew up in Texas there's a lot.
- You guys are horrified.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That's I'm sorry.
- No, I just, I think
being naked is funny.
Okay, here we go let's do
another one. (gameshow sounds)
(ding sound)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Helen] Oh, oh dear.
- Shoots.
- [Kelly] We are all going to hell.
(audience laughs)
(Helen laughs)
Oh, wait what have you stolen?
- I've stolen when I was at
college and I had no money.
I mean, no money.
I was literally, you know
sort of starving really.
I occasionally would steal food.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- From the supermarket I have to say.
- [Kelly] That's like I have
to say, I feel like yeah.
I mean stealings not good but that's.
- I felt very guilty, but I was you know,
I was in the serious need so.
- [Kelly] I wish that we would've ended
with you cuz we're about
to sound like major (beep).
(guests laugh)
Like I'm gonna go with that
story too I was so hungry.
(audience laugh)
- I was stealing food for the needy.
(Kelly laughs)
(Helen laughs)
- [Kelly] What did you steal?
- I was, when I was like 12,
I had a little shoplifting
phase with a friend.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] A phase?!
- Yeah, like a season a seasonal...
There was a thing like
I feel like certain,
I don't know if it was my sister
I'm not trying to out her, but I feel
like there was a certain
time when it was just
like a fun thing people would just go do.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- [Helen] Liberate the goods I was told
- [Kelly] Liberate the goods!
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes.
There was a friend of mine
called it liberating the goods.
- [Kelly] Oh. I don't wanna tell mine.
I'm gonna look like a jack hole.
Mines like kind of sad.
I don't wanna tell mine.
- [Adam] Yeah. Come on.
(audience cheering)
- Aww.
It's gonna kinda sad.
Okay. I aww this is okay this
person actually doesn't know.
Cause I've only stolen one
thing like my whole life
and it was home.
It said, home is where the heart is and it
I know it's gonna get sad here.
Okay. Anyway, but it
was like cross stitched.
It was like this beautiful
thing at this woman's house
that my, that would watch
me whenever cuz my mom was
a single mom at the time
and she would watch me
and we moved a lot and I just
didn't feel like I had that.
So see it got sad.
So I took it cuz I just thought it was.
- This is equally sad.
(Helen laughs)
- I know but it's horrible.
It's probably like some
kind of family heirloom
and then the universe or God shamed me and
I lost it so I couldn't even give it back.
So I couldn't even give it back.
I lost it, anyway. I'm going to hell.
Hit the button.
- [Adam] I don't so.
(gameshow sounds)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(ding sound)
Tried psychedelics.
You're damed if you
have tried psychedelia.
Yeah!!
- Here's my thing I would
totally do it. I just haven't.
- [Adam] You get to drink if you would.
- I Would, I think I would.
In a controlled environment.
I've saw this whole thing
on Fantastic Fun on Netflix
and they the doctors it can kind of
reach a different part of
you and it opens you up.
- [Helen] It's very interesting
now what's happening
with psychedelics.
- [Kelly] I know.
I mean, I think.
- Think in like a say
- Revisiting them as a tool.
- Yeah I'm into that.
I saw something.
- I took LSD once with very close friends.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it was absolutely spectacular.
It was.
- I hear this.
- [Helen] It was amazing.
- Yeah.
- And it, and I said I'm
never doing that again
because it was so, so extreme.
And, and I don't know, I just.
- [Adam] But that was only last week.
- Its beautiful.
- So you dunno.
- [Kelly] She might try
again. (guests laugh)
- As beautiful as it as it was,
I didn't want to lose control
in that way again.
- [Kelly] Ooh.
- You know of my mind.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I think that's a solid statement.
- [Helen] Yeah
- Yeah, you don't wanna
lose control of your mind.
(guests laugh)
(audience cheers)
And that is Your damed if you do.
Shazam Fury Of The Gods
is in theaters now,
including in Imax.
Everybody goes see it.